[Music]
mahogany workplace which I just did a
bit of a dive into this morning
you wrote a post is sort of about your
advice on when one is looking back on
relationships and well the first thing
you said is you need to figure out what
broke so when you're looking back on
your own relationships especially a
pretty big TV one you had yeah what have
you learned about what broke I have to
start taking responsibility for some of
it because it's so easy to be the victim
oh you know they treated me this way or
they treated me this way and and so when
you start looking inward and saying okay
what exactly that I do that affected
this breakup or this relationship
negatively for me it's my reactions
towards things when I first started
dating Lauren and we started really
having a very serious relationship where
I was trying to share everything with
her and she was sharing with everything
with me my reaction towards stuff was
sometimes so bad I would I would react
because it wasn't what I expected or
wasn't what I was normal or used to I'm
an only child
so I have I have routines and
consistencies in my life that for
anybody else to come in and change that
for me I was holding on to him way too
close so I have to become less
reactionary the other part of this and
I'm too sensitive I just get so
sensitive sometimes and that affects
just my normal relationships because I
doubt all the time to back my head you
know is this relationship for real do
they really like me do they really care
or let's throw an out there do they
really love me
and I guess that's something I have to
give up because when I start getting my
own head about that I start to push the
person away so do you feel ready for a
relationship right now
this the schedule is if the schedule is
hard and I think part of that is because
I'm I'm pushing relationships away
because I don't know if I'm ready and
I'm just using this time to continue to
promote and push and operate some things
I really care about but I would like to
say I'm more ready today than I was a
few months ago and and it's in the back
of my head a lot you know that I really
want a family especially holding a baby
this week in Los Angeles I I have a
picture I'll show you afterwards let me
hold the baby last night I'm like that
looks good married to your career right
now that I feel that sounds so terrible
that's exactly yeah or does it sound
like this is the life place you're in
and that's great
yeah I would say that I am dating oh and
excited about my career and really
passionate about the things happening in
my life when it comes to to my career
and that I hope that this season life
sets me up to be able to work for
generous with generous long-term so that
when relationship is solidified and it's
something that I want to you know
continue to pursue that generous is the
way that we're putting food on the table
okay three things you're looking for in
a woman
honesty vulnerability and a ton of love
and three reasons that people should go
buy a bag of generous coffee right now
you see me light up I got this one it
truly is the highest quality coffee out
there with a specialty coffee so it is
graded as as the world class category of
coffee all coffee or any products
purchased the profits are going back to
causes that are fighting some type of
injustice in the world right now we're
focusing on developing jobs for women in
Honduras let's start purchasing products
that are giving back that are of the
highest quality because it means
something
[Music]
you